[Musique]
prenez une douche froide c'est pas une
bonne idée on a l'impression qu'on va se
refroidir mais en fait on risque de
créer un choc thermique et le corps il a
horreur des variations de température
dans un sens ou dans l'autre donc il
vaut mieux prendre une douche à
température pour éviter les efforts une
fatigue des efforts pour que l'organisme
se remettent à la température qui est la
température 37° finalement donc il faut
plutôt une douche fraîche qu'on va
prendre en plus ça va favoriser
l'endormissement donc ni une douche trop
chaude ni une douche froide ça ça serait
de très mauvaise idée
[Musique]
boire trop d'eau à boire plus de trois
litres c'est pas la bonne idée en
période de canicule de forte chaleur
quand on dit qu'il faut voir il faut
boire 1,5 à 2 litres d'eau si on boit
trop si on boit plus de 3 litres 4
litres 5 litres et bien on a les risques
d'intoxication de noyade intérieure en
particulier chez les personnes âgées
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'hyponatrémie
dire que le sel qu'on a à l'intérieur du
corps si on boit trop il va se diluer sa
donne d oedème au niveau du cerveau ça
donne des troubles neurologiques et on a
malheureusement des cas de réanimation
voire de décès à cause d'une hyper
hydratation
on dit qu'il faut s'hydrater mais faut
s'hydrater avec des boissons qui sont à
température température ambiante
températures un peu au frigo
éventuellement mais surtout pas des
boissons très glacée pour la simple et
bonne raison que quand on va les
ingurgiter quand on va avaler la boisson
elle va se mettre à température et le
corps pour mettre la boisson à
température qu'elle soit très froides ou
qu'elle soit très chaude va consommer de
l'énergie et va produire de la
transpiration et si vous produisez la
transpiration et bien c'est un facteur
déshydratation donc le meilleur moyen
c'est une boisson allées autour de 12 14
degrés par exemple ça permet d'avoir une
température ambiante de s'hydrater
correctement dans des quantités
raisonnables
[Musique]
m la clim à fond ça peut être aussi le
réflexe on arrive on est dans un bureau
il fait très chaud à l'extérieur et je
vais aller mettre à fond la clim pour
avoir une grosse différence de
température et bien c'est ça le problème
c'est la grosse différence de
température parce que le corps va avoir
du mal à supporter cette différence de
température entre l'extérieur et
l'intérieur je parle même pas des
raisons écologiques mais juste pour des
raisons physiologiques
le corps a besoin d'avoir une
température à peu près constante donc
s'il fait très chaud à l'extérieur il
faut pas faire un choc de 15 degrés de
température s'il fait 42 or pas question
de mettre la clim à 20 ou 25 on va
mettre une crime rafraîchissante mais on
va faire attention à avoir une
température qui est une température
modérée la bière c'est avant tout
l'alcool
or on sait que l'alcool c'est un facteur
de déshydratation donc on va avoir un
effet immédiat de cette bière fraîche
qui va peut-être faire du bien mais ça
va être très court terme et à moyen
terme malheureusement ça va déshydraté
ça va obliger à revoir et la meilleure
manière de s'hydrater c'est vraiment de
l'eau quand je parle de bière il faut
éviter tous les alcools alcools forts
pastis bière en période de canicule
vraiment c'est une très mauvaise idée
[Musique]
si on met le ventilateur trop près de
soi on risque d'avoir une irritation des
voies aériennes par exemple quand vous
êtes dans un avion on sait très bien
qu'on a un peu mal à la gorge et donc on
risque un certain nombre d'infections
par exemple qui sont bénignes pas mourir
parce qu'on met le ventilateur proche de
son visage mais en revanche c'est
désagréable et ça serait dommage de
chopé un virus par exemple en plein été
et puis on sait que le ventilateur chez
les personnes âgées ou qui ont le coeur
un peu fragile c'est pas forcément une
très bonne idée non plus en tout cas
quand il est proche de soi donc il faut
plutôt l'éloigner